[music playing]
NARRATOR: Tell Abu Habbah, Iraq.
In the Iraqi desert, just 18
miles southwest of Baghdad,
lie the ruins of
ancient Babylonia.
In 1881, archaeologists
digging at the ancient site
unearthed tens of thousands
of stone tablets dating
back to the sixth century BC.
Amongst the finds
was a bass-relief
carving depicting the
Mesopotamian sun-god Shamash.
This here is the
Babylonian tablet
of Shamash, which
has the central disc
right here with god
Shamash right here
and human beings right here.
What's so cool in
this depiction is
that Shamash is shown as if
he was some type of a giant
because he's much, much bigger
than the rest of the people
here.
The enclosure has this type
of a connection to the cosmos,
because you've a depiction of
the moon, the sun, and Venus.
Now, what I think is really
cool is that up here you
have the celestial
being that is sort
of holding on to this disc.
The fact that this celestial
being has these two ropes
attached to this disc
leads me to think
about misunderstood technology.
The sun disc in
the tablet of Shamash
is described in the
below text as such:
The disc was sent there
or put there to be
worshipped in place of Shamash.
It was the access point
for the ancient Babylonians
to communicate
with their gods, in
particular the sun-god Shamash.
This could actually be
some method of communicating
with the god himself.
It is some form of a technology.
Think of it as sort
of a god button
that the ancient Babylonians
or Sumerians could push
and be able to
connect with Shamash.
NARRATOR: If the actual sun
disc depicted on the tablet
is ever found among the
ruins of ancient Babylonia,
will we discover that it is some
sort of technological device?
Perhaps further
clues can be found
by examining the story
of an Incan ruler
who wore a disc
which allowed him
to wield the power of the gods.